we're about three months out from the
all-important midterms and democrats who
were hoping things would turn around by
now are in for a rude awakening turns
out the american people aren't feeling
that great in biden's america a new poll
found almost three-quarters of voters
say the country is headed in the wrong
direction 58 percent say america's best
days are behind it that is an all-time
high
and fox news projecting republicans to
win the majority in the house by at
least two seats
but there is one silver lining for the
democrats joe biden is still on vacation
ever notice that the more out of sight
joe stays the party does a little bit
better well 60 democrats facing tough
elections caught on and they told the
washington post biden should keep his
distance quote few candidates said they
wanted biden to campaign for them in
their state or district with many not
responding to the question at all the
post also asked if candidates wanted
vice president harris is a surrogate
campaigner for the biden administration
and got the same set of unenthusiastic
responses
ouch
and democrats get even more cagey when
the cameras are rolling watch would you
want president biden to come to arizona
and campaign with you
hey i'll welcome anybody to come to
arizona that's not exactly an open
invitation to president biden i want to
be the face of this campaign and i don't
want any distractions i am not talking
about 2022 i'm not talking about 2024. i
i intend to do the campaigning myself i
am the candidate it's my name on the
ballot
who is that last congresswoman abigail
spanberg there she is dana so it's
really awkward do you would you have a
better set of talking points to advise
democrats to use besides those or is
that the best they can i think that
might be the best they can do but i
think that journalists could do a little
bit better in asking a follow-up
question
would you like president obama to come
campaign with you and what do you think
the answer to that would be that is good
that is absolutely yes i'd love it
please i will do anything and then they
could do a third do you want michelle
obama to come up
that's like the universal yes the nbc
news poll really sent shock waves but it
shouldn't because these numbers have
been the same the media had written so
many comeback kid stories that they
believed that the passage of the
inflation reduction act was all of a
sudden going to magically change things
not only that but the president signed
it and he stayed on vacation when you
have an advantage like that you press it
so you sign the bill and then you start
traveling around the country like they
always say they want to do they always
say they want to get out in the country
and talk to more people and see more
people they didn't do that they've been
on vacation and now what do we have then
the news cycle changes and now we're
talking about the raid at mar-a-lago um
ron claim the chief of staff said that
biden was like
fdr jfk lbj eisenhower and bill clinton
because he passed a bill
to give rich people tax credits and
double the size of the irs and i don't
think that that's going to fly with a
lot of people and
come november 15th by by thanksgiving
you're going to see the media have to go
back out in the country and interview
all those people again and say gosh why
didn't you change your mind
about the direction of the country even
though the president passed the largest
climate bill in history
yeah i don't think bill clinton wants to
be compared to joe biden i don't think
he likes that at all what do you think
johnny joey jones they're just joey
jones there's some truth in that i mean
he's stuck around for too long and he's
feeble he's probably in office because
of some cabal of like mafia uh movement
uh he's probably he's shown himself to
be somewhat racist in certain ways with
eisenhower i think eisenhower did a
little bit better with china and who was
the other one bill clinton he's
certainly going to have a white house
full of scandals so there are some
comparisons there but i think it stops
there i think it stops with the
negatives uh listen this is not a hard
thing to understand the white house has
probably told these people listen this
man cannot physically campaign with you
so don't don't entertain that don't
don't try to bring it down here you
can't do it it's all i can do to ride a
bicycle on the beach to be fair that's
not something i could do
but when you talk about where americans
are some of these polls talk about their
that they think america um is worse than
it's ever been they think it's hit its
peak and is and has been in a recession
of just american greatness you just look
go down the list let me talk about okay
strong on defense well ukraine
afghanistan uh the wokeness of the
military nobody's excited about that
even if you're not upset about it you're
not excited about it you talk about
inflation all the different problems and
none of them have been actually
addressed by at least this package and
we're talking about workforce shortage
production deficiencies import problems
regulate regulatory costs spending
spending and oh yeah spending
immigration the border and fentanyl
those are two big issues that people are
going to care about and then we get down
to crime we're talking cashless bill
defunding the police refocusing federal
agencies on their political opponents
and then local law enforcement is left
to do what the federal agencies should
have done so then they can't do the
crime in their cities and on top of that
you have border patrol in the fbi that
that one needs all the resources and the
other one is is using it in ways that
leaves us baffled that's the legacy of
president biden no matter how many
band-aid pieces of legislation they hang
their hat on republicans hung their hat
on the trump tax cuts you know what
democrats didn't see that as success
don't ask me to see spending spending
and spending as a legislative success
just because joe manchin gave gave the
the flip of the hand to uh mitt romney
or to uh mitch mcconnell doesn't mean
that all of a sudden president biden
is the guy that can get things done i
mean maybe chuck schumer is
jones brings up an interesting point
campos hopefully a couple
this one i'm really into
excuse me
sean
he might not physically be capable of
flying all the way to arizona or flying
once he's over there all the way up to
nevada nevada nevada
those are long flights that are very
taxing for someone like that do you
think he might not even be up to it
that's entirely possible i mean there's
all kinds of video evidence we have that
by the way presidential comparisons
maybe they could campaign with liz
cheney who now says she's abraham
lincoln
so that's that's one way to look at it i
think part of it um you hit it on the
head dana you know they can't go he
can't go out and talk about the
inflation reduction act and brag about
it because they admitted after they
passed it that it wasn't that that it
was a climate bill and if they thought a
climate bill or the green new deal was
popular they would have named the bill
the climate deal or the green new deal
and they didn't because they know the
american people don't want that so now
he's going to have to go around and all
of them i think are going to have a
problem answering
to that bill because people did not want
that they literally the number one issue
is inflation which is why they named it
the inflation reduction act but it
doesn't do that um so i think there's a
lot of problems by the way mark kelly
all these people they don't want him in
the district because he's toxic nobody
has had worse numbers than he has um
they're actually trying right now to
pretend that they're moderates so having
joe biden next to him is not going to
help um the other thing is even aoc
doesn't want him um in her district and
he's doing everything he wanted she
asked him to do which is pretty
ungrateful of her that is she's very
ungrateful that's what people say i
didn't say that
what about that number that's an
all-time high people think america's
best days are behind us that's where do
you attribute that to harold ford jr
people aren't happy um i think first of
all glad you're back thank god to be
around the table uh been away a week
myself i missed you too
i'd say a couple things
say a couple of things so sweet when you
see the polls if you believe polls you
got to believe them when they're good
and when they're bad
there's some good things in this for
democrats there's some bad things
without a question three out of four
americans believe on the wrong track um
that has happened before when president
bush was in office there was a time in
06 when people didn't necessarily want
him to come president clinton people and
won him in 94. i don't imagine many
republicans are going to ask president
trump to come
uh in the tough races in the senate and
congressional races going forward so
that happens
the enthusiasm however is very good
but for the first time well just let's
just step up the polls for one second
the the enthusiasm level has narrowed
democrats are only two points behind
republicans from three months ago so the
poll we analyzed on the show before i
try to call balls and strikes i pray
that i do and we were in a bad situation
but you have an enthusiasm level that is
caught up you also have generic polling
information which is caught up as well
two inflation is flattening may not we
can we can argue about it gas is below
four dollars unemployment is at all
almost at an all-time low
and whatever you want to say about this
bill it's going to allow for medicare to
negotiate with pharmaceutical companies
which we've never had before we tried it
when i was in congress which seems like
a long long time ago but we weren't able
to succeed in doing it furthermore joe
manchin agreed to this also because
we're going to do more domestic energy
production including things that i
believe and i think we believe around
this table fossil fuels and there's a
belief in my party and i happen to agree
that we got to get greener but we can't
abandon fossil fuels as we try to do it
finally i'll quote mitch mcconnell
republicans i think probably have a
candidate challenge also with some of
the senate candidates when you look at
the fact that the roe v wade or kcb
pennsylvania was overturned by the court
that clearly is a big factor what i
found also interesting day and i'd be
curious your thoughts on this the number
one issue in this poll now or at least
when the top two
voters have never cited this it's
threats to our democracy or on the minds
of voters democrats are going to say
that means if they don't like trump they
they believe what happened on january 6
is a rough tough thing republicans might
counter with that people don't like the
way that they search the president's
home in mar-a-lago we'll find out one
thing's for certain things have changed
in three months polls at this point are
not conclusive they're instructive three
months from now this poll looks like
this i think we'll have a different tune
and we might even be able to say with
some more definitiveness what this may
mean well i don't know a single
republican that wouldn't want donald
trump to come campaign for maybe you can
think of that republican in the break
but i can't think of one right now hi
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now